EU ministers in charge of energy policy  will look into the reasons behind rising  energy bills in Europe and analyze the  impact on energy consumers and the  political implications according to a  commission report electricity prices for  industries in Europe are twice as high  as those in the United States and twenty  percent higher than in China it's even  worse when comparing gas prices between  the EU and its main trading partners  these are three to four times higher  than comparable US and Russian tariffs  this gap makes it difficult for the EU  to compete with them in attracting  industrial activity finding a lasting  solution to bring down energy prices is  key to fostering competitiveness and  restoring growth in the European Union  like their environment counterparts the  previous day EU energy ministers will  debate the new framework for climate and  energy policy for 2030 the results will  feed into discussions during the spring  European Council in March